hey what's up guys mkbhd here and today
we're going to be taking a look at
android 4.1 jelly bean on the galaxy
nexus now if you want to get jelly bean
early on your rooted galaxy nexus before
the ota comes in around mid july you can
find those at the links down in the
description but either way let's just
get right into it let's take a look at
the top five features of this brand new
and amazingly awesome new operating
system
so right off the bat the first awesome
new feature is project butter and that
is what's going to allow the new user
interface of android 4.1 to be extremely
fast now the camera doesn't even really
do it justice here i reviewed the galaxy
nexus earlier and you saw it was pretty
responsive on camera but this is like
using an entirely different device this
is as responsive as the quad core galaxy
s3 animations are all very fast thanks
to all the brand new uh tricks of google
sleeve like triple buffering and vsync
and basically everything is at a very
very high frame rate pulling down the
notification panel everything is
extremely responsive scrolling through
lists pinching to zoom everything is
very very fast now so it feels like a
new device obviously it has a new
operating system but this is just a
whole new level especially the
multitasking if i have a bunch of
applications open that multitasking is
instantaneous and i really like the fact
that it's so fast so that is the first
new feature
obviously it's probably the best new
feature for a lot of people just wanting
to experience the smoothness of android
and it's something that a lot of people
had complaints about earlier so
definitely the new smoothness thanks to
project butter is an awesome new
improvement
number two feature is the new
notification panel and as we can already
tell android notifications are already
really impressive but now first of all
when we pull down the notification panel
it's a beautiful new look besides the
new functionality so you can see it
tends to fade that down until it's
almost black here's a new look of the
notification panel absolutely beautiful
and you'll notice the expanded
notifications here and the contracted
notifications and basically there are
two finger gestures you can use to
contract and expand notifications so as
you can see here i have 171 new messages
and i can just go ahead and contract and
expand them if i want to look at them
and if i want to dismiss it of course
you can do the same thing as you could
earlier by swiping them out and there's
also a clear all button but here's the
clean beautiful new notifications panel
obviously this is a lot prettier than
the last version as you can see when i
touch the bottom it turns cyan blue when
i'm touching it then i let go and it's
gray so i think that's really cool also
and you have a shortcut to your settings
and of course you have your time and
your data up here which is all in the
nice beautiful roboto font that was
introduced in ice cream sandwich so the
new notification tray is absolutely top
notch if you had something here that you
could reply to say a text message you
could swipe down and open up some
options and have a reply button right
there or if you have a missed call you
can swipe down on the missed call and
hit the reply button to the missed call
so of course you have a lot of control
over your notifications here
that's just android taking notifications
to the next level and of course all of
this maintains its super smoothness
thanks to project butter the third also
new thing is new home screen
improvements which allow you to organize
a lot better so as you can see here we
have of course our app tray and then our
widgets over to the side but more
importantly you're able to move around
widgets and position them accordingly so
if i want to drag this widget to the
bottom it'll make way for the widget
that i want to add which is pretty cool
so if i have a home screen with not a
lot of room on it and i want to add
another widget here like maybe this
books widget it'll tell me where i can
move things out the way apps will move
out the way this is the application for
books but stuff will move out the way to
get out of the way of where i'm going to
put this down
and it'll even resize some things if i
want to put something down that's a
resizable widget so for example
bookmarks here it's a resizable widget i
drag it to the top it resizes it to be
of course a smaller widget because it
won't take up this space here
drag this up move around the shortcuts
everything moves out the way it's very
very fluid and responsive too so no
worries about having any questions about
where you're going to drop something the
grid that it used to display when you're
moving stuff around is gone but you do
get the levels here with us still the
hollow outline
number four and you can already tell
we're saving the best for last but
number four is just the minor things
there are a lot of new minor
improvements in ice cream sandwich for
example when i go to widgets here we can
see that there are some just very very
impressive looking widgets here they all
look very clean thanks to the new
outline uh say we're in a new keyboard
and we want to take a look at our
keyboard here the new keyboard with
predictive text you can choose to
download offline speech to text
recognition it's only 22 megabytes in
the settings and this also turns into a
down arrow instead of a back arrow so
when you have your keyboard open it
turns into a down arrow just all this
little stuff that android and google
have have put into their new product
here if i go ahead and open the search
and i go ahead and type in the name of
an app like dropbox here i'll see what
happens you get the icon for the dropbox
app in the search notifications so
that's pretty awesome all this little
stuff is coming together to really just
polish the operating system up a lot of
people are complaining that ice cream
sandwich wasn't actually that polished i
think it's the most polished version of
the operating system yet but jelly bean
is definitely on a whole new level of
polish it has pretty much made this
a really enjoyable option and definitely
a very affordable option if you're
looking to get this over like a galaxy
s3 i could see someone buying this over
the galaxy s3 this is definitely much
more polished than it was before and
very enjoyable and easy to use but of
course last but not least is google
voice search and google now you can see
this new persistent search bar up at the
top if you want to of course google
search something you can tap here and
then you can begin typing just like any
regular google search but google now is
available on the lock screen so if i go
ahead and swipe up it'll bring us to
google now and if you watch the video
about google now that's in the
description you get an idea that this is
really responsive to you that's right
you it's going to know things about you
and show these cards based on what you
have been telling it what you like to
search things like that and we'll go
ahead and go through a few
voice search things now you'll notice
this is not quite as conversational as
something like s voice or siri but it is
miles better than the previous versions
of android voice search so we'll go
ahead and start with something simple
like some math
stay here
12 plus 13.
the answer is 25
and here that the voice it uses is very
natural but it's pretty quiet so i'll
turn up the volume here
next thing we'll do is some geography
maybe
how big is russia
[Music]
wow
russia has an area
so it gives that it also gives your
source and it also gives an image so if
you're ever uncomfortable with the
source you can always check out the web
results which will always be below it if
it doesn't come up with a card for your
answer it'll just go straight to your
web results
[Music]
when is barack obama's birthday
[Music]
barack obama's date of birth is august
4th 1961. it's very fast
how tall is usain bolt
[Music]
usain bolt is six feet five inches tall
cool
what's the weather like in los angeles
[Music]
69 degrees and clear in los angeles
here's the forecast for the next few
days so as you can see it's extremely
fast very responsive i'll ask it some
more complicated questions now like here
are there any good pizza places nearby
[Music]
as you can see it's not as
conversational so if you ask it
something that's more of a sentence than
an actual search query it'll probably
deliver search results but here as you
can see it gives a bunch of search
results for pizza places that are nearby
and lets you view them on google maps
lets you call them view their addresses
all sorts of cool stuff so it's very
cool let's check out a few more things
for example you can use it as a tool to
send a note to yourself as an email
note to self go big groceries tomorrow
[Music]
and as you can see it'll send a note to
yourself to go get groceries tomorrow
sends it as an email to your own email
address based on what the phone has
pretty awesome
navigate to galloping hills golf course
[Music]
navigating so it's pretty impressive if
you let the timer run out it'll
automatically navigate to the golf
course which is pretty awesome so as you
can see s voice is no match for google's
new
voice stuff this is a miles better
thumbs up on this video if you want to
see a comparison with maybe siri or s
voice or something like that if i can
get my hands on an iphone i will
definitely try to do that
so there you go guys that is what is new
in jelly bean and i'm definitely excited
to see this come on newer devices
hopefully samsung and htc make some
announcements to stay competitive and
get the newest version on their flagship
devices either way if you like this
video be feel free to give it a thumbs
up and be sure to subscribe for more
videos like this i think i just pointed
yeah there's a subscribe button be sure
to subscribe if you want to stay tuned
for more videos like this as i produce
some all the time now either way thanks
for watching and i will talk to you guys
in the next video
peace
[Music]
you